the size of the set A1 this isn't a problem if we know in advance how many solutions there are but
if we don't know how many solutions there are in advance we don't know what Theta is so we can't pick T like this
and we'll have to do something different I'll come back to the situation where we don't know s a little bit later but to
start let's focus on the situation in which we do know how many solutions there are beginning with unique search
where there's guaranteed to be a single unique solution that we're looking
for I mentioned the unique search problem as an example of a query problem back in lesson
five the input is a function f from nbits to one bit there's a unique n bit
string that causes F to evaluate to one and the goal is to Output that string so
this is equivalent to the unstructured search problem we've been talking about but with the promise that there's exactly one solution and in fact this is
the only version of the search problem that love Grover considered in his original 1996 paper that introduced Grover's
algorithm for Unique search we have that s equals 1 and therefore this important angle Theta is equal to the inverse sign
of the square root of 1 n when n is large this value is approximately theare root of 1/ N and
that's because for smaller and smaller angles the sign function starts to look more and more like the identity
function if we substitute that approximation into our selection for T we see that t is approximately the floor
of pi over 4 * the < TK of n that's good because we're on track to be using Big O of the square root of n
queries though at this point we've yet to take a look at exactly how well the algorithm
performs let's take a look at an example where capital N is 128 which is 2 ^ 7 so
our function f is from Seven bits to one bit and we're assuming that there's a unique solution but to figure out how
well the algorithm works we really only need to concern ourselves with the angle Theta which we can calculate it's
approximately 0.08 85 radians which is a little bit more than 5° and if we plug that value into our
expression for T we get eight so we're thinking about what happens when we search for a unique solution out of 128
possibilities using eight queries we can draw a picture to illustrate how the state changes over
time as we perform iterations of the grover operation as before we have the states K
a0 and K A1 and in this particular case meaning unique search we have that Kat A1 is in fact the standard basis State
corresponding to the unique solution whatever it happens to be well K a0 is the uniform superposition over all
strings besides the unique solution here's the uniform superposition over all strings which we
can write as cosine Theta K a0 plus sin Theta K A1 and it makes sense that K a0
and K U are close in this case because as we just observed a moment ago K a0 is
almost the uniform superposition over all strings there's only one string missing and that's the unique solution applying G again rotates by an
additional 2 Theta so this is where we are after two iterations here's three 4 5 6 7 and 8
and now we see that we're pretty close to Kat A1 so if we stop and measure at this point we'll be quite likely to get
the unique solution and in fact in this case there's only about a half a percent chance that we don't get the unique
Solution on the other hand if we were to continue applying the grover operation more than the recommended eight times
then the probability to get a solution would go back down and over time it would oscillate as the state goes around
the circle so it's important that we stop the iterations at the right time if we want to succeed with high
probability let's think about about the probability that our choice for T reveals the unique solution more generally for different values of
n we'll write pn1 to denote the probability that Grover's algorithm succeeds in finding a unique solution
for each possible value of n the one means one solution and we'll extend this notation to other numbers of solutions
shortly here's a table of these probabilities for small powers of two it's starts with Nal 2 and the
probability is 1 12 which isn't very good but then for Nal 4 the probability is exactly one so it actually works
perfectly in this case it's a great exercise by the way to explicitly go through how these two cases work
particularly the case that n is equal to four in that case we're searching for one solution out of four possibilities
we need just a single query and it works perfectly as n get gets larger we do see some fluctuations the probabilities go
up and down a little bit but they appear to be getting closer to one and indeed that is true it can be proved
analytically that the probability is always at least 1 - 1 / n so that's good
the algorithm isn't perfect we're not guaranteed to get a solution but it's quite likely particularly for large
values of n as well as the very interesting anomaly that happens when n is equal to 4
I should also point out that we can always run the entire algorithm including the measurements as many times as we choose and if any one of the runs
succeeds we'll get a solution so if these probabilities aren't good enough we can easily boost them by just running
the algorithm again in fact even if these probabilities were all equal to 1/2 for instance we'd still have a
useful searching algorithm now let's consider what happens when there are multiple
Solutions we'll start with a similar example example to the one before again n is equal to 128 but this time the
number of solutions s is four rather than 1 again we can calculate Theta and T and
we get that Theta is about 01777 or a bit more than 10° and T is
four this time so the angle is about twice the value from the previous example and T is half of what it
was we can draw a picture like before here's where we
start here's one iteration two three and four this time we're very close to cat
A1 and the probability to get a solution this time turns out to be greater than
99.9% but if we didn't know any better and we thought that there was only one solution we would take T to B8 like
before we'd rotate almost all the way around to negative K a0 and that would lead to a very small probability of
success so that's a further example showing that there are good choices of T and bad choices of T and here we see